مقابل انخفاض درجه الحراره في مدينه ابها
هي ميزه اكسبت منتزه السحاب شعبيه سياحيه
خلال فصل الصيف المنتزه يقع على مرتفعات
السوداء واطلاله على تهامه وعلى القرى
المحيط
[موسيقى]
من امام المنتزه السحابي ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه وسام القاسم حياك الله يا اسامه
شيل تغير في منتزه السحاب في صيف ابها
2023 اهلا وسهلا خالي تحيه طيبه لك ولجميع
المشاهدين العربيه نعم الصوت والصوره من
هنا من منتزه السحاب احدى المناطق التي تم
تهيئتها في موسم سيف عسير 2003 هذا
المنتزه الذي يمتاز بانخفاض درجات الحراره
درجه الحراره الان هنا في منتزه السحاب
تصل الى 18 درجه مئويه وهي تعتبر من اقل
المناطق في ارتفاع درجات الحراره وجود
الزوار والسياح وهم ياتون الى هذه المناطق
الاستمتاع بالاجواء البارده تقريبا من
الساعه الواحده مساء كانت جميع هذه
المناطق ممتلئه بالكامل وتشهد توافدا
باستمرار تام هنا طبعا ساتحدث بنقطه مهمه
جدا اهمها انه يمنع الاحتطاب ويمنع صيد
الحيوانات ويمنع ايضا اطعام الحيوانات
هؤلاء الشبان يعيشون هذه الاجواء الممتعه
والاكواب الشاي بالتاكيد والكل هنا يستمتع
بهذه الاجواء الايام ايضا قد تكون هناك
انخفاضات وارده جدا في درجات الحراره في
الامس تقريبا عشرين درجه مئويه اليوم 18
درجه مئويه هذه الاجواء اليوم ساهمت في
خلق صوره كبيره جدا وسط هذه المدرجات
الخضراء نحن نتواجد على جبل وبجانبنا ايضا
تهامه عسير كل هذه المناطق اليوم اصبحت
مغريه جدا لاي زائر او سائح حينما ياتي
الى جنوب السعوديه لقضاء موسم الصيف طبعا
كل هذه المناطق تم تهيئتها بجميع الخدمات
من الجهات المسؤوله هيئه تطوير عصير اعلنت
عن خمسه عشر منطقه تم تخصيصها لمثل هذه
المناطق للاستمتاع بهذه الاجواء وايضا
لايات الزائر وسائر على جدول ممنهج بحيث
انه يعلم المناطق التي سيذهب اليها وما هي
الخدمات المتوفره وما هي ميزه التنافسيه
التي تحصل بين هذه المناطق 15 منطقه تم
تهيئتها انا اتحدث عن 15 منطقه متوزعه على
جميع محافظات عسير منها المناطق الجبليه
ومنها المناطق التهاميه ايضا مناطق
الفعاليات المخصصه للفعاليات والمزوده
بالتاكيد والتي تم احيائها بعدد من
المطاعم والمقاهي نلحظ الان ايضا توافد
الكثير من السياح هناك ايضا في المنطقه
العلويه توافد كثير جدا للسياح والزوار
لاحظنا ايضا ان اغلب الزوار ياتون الى هذه
المناطق البارده سواء منتزه السحاب او
النماص او تنوما ليعيشوا هذه اجواء
البارده ايضا
راحتهم ويطبخون ويعيشون اجواء رائعه جدا
وسط هذه الاجواء المثاليه بالتاكيد في صيف
موسم عسير 2023 شكرا لك يعطيك العافيه
اسامه القاسم
[موسيقى]